so I still want to think about four
drawers okay so maybe I will draw this
okay so four drawers still happen okay
but this time I'm interested in not a
win in all four drawers okay I'm
interested in a win in one of the
drawers okay so the same sequence of
events has happened but now I'm
interested in a different probability
okay different probability so what are
we the possibility of winning and I own
what wants right not not at least once
exactly once how would this happen hmm
we're in one of the four drawers now
think about it again
you've got all your little compliment
all your options on the board I've
already got one way that this can happen
I've already got a way that this could
happen can you see by the way there's
only one one of the alternatives here
that will give you actually on earth no
no I don't I've got a few different ones
what's what's one possible way just one
possible way that this can happen okay
good
I could I could lose so I don't win and
then lose again and then lose again and
then what was it well not those I'm
lucky full time lucky vaguer I won I won
exactly once okay that's one way it can
happen right but clearly it's not the
only way right all of these events
happen simultaneously but if you rewind
the clock you could do it differently
what's an example
I could I suppose I could win first and
then and then say wow I'm doing lucky
this is great and do another four times
and lose all of my money after that
lose-lose we go to alternatives but
you're starting to see a pattern here
aren't you
right how many more alternatives are
there there are two more and it's very
illogical to see by the way this is why
it's so important to write it out in a
helpful way it's very easy to see what
the alternatives are this is winning on
a four time this is when you on the
first time you could win on a second at
that time there you go
now these can't all have been at the
same time this is 16 draws not for right
so they have to be happening separately
now I just need to work out what a kick
what are the probabilities of each of
these right let's think about the first
one how would I work it out these guys
in here they're all happening
simultaneously right so what's the
probability of not winning for the first
draw it's on 115 I know what's the
probability of not winning for the
second drill still 59 60 and for the
third drawer
it'll still be 59 over CC so I'm gonna
write that okay all right now then the
last thing happens I win at last I win
that's the probability there's the
problem in the first one now how does
the probability of the second alternate
how does it compare to the one we just
considered yes it's exactly the same it
just happens in a different order okay
but if you want to get all fancy on if
you go back to the Year seven we have a
name for the war for different kinds of
operations that you can do in different
orders namely if that's at the scene
anyone know multiplication approach rule
is um it's commutated
so you can rearrange it however you like
so it doesn't matter whether you're
winners first or last or second or third
okay they're all going to be the same so
what can I do
I could just multiply like that how do
we ever to write up so what's this going
to be equal to this will be 4 times 59
cubed on that denominator you gave me
before I don't know what 4 times you've
seen hi cutie skin someone don't 8 2 1 5
1 6 okay so I guess we got to combine
discovery your calculator can take care
of it okay that's not where we're
worried about computers calculators are
for answers human self questions okay so
we're worried about this process the
calculator can handle the rest
okay so you can see we use the
peripheral and the addition rule here
because there are separate things